we've got
biden as president we talked about this
yesterday
what do you think the vegas odds are and
i don't know if you can bet on politics
in vegas but you can overseas
you can bet on what are the odds he
served his entire term four years
biden i told you the number i said 70
percent
but you wouldn't you wouldn't bet me
50 50. no not even money i bet you 10 or
1.
i bet you 100 grand to 10 grand but you
think there's a 70 percent chance he's
going to survive yeah but i'm betting
you 10 awesome let's just just just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
if you think this is a 70 percent chance
well if you think there's a 70 chance an
even money bet would be a good bet for
you then
you're betting he's going to serve i say
he won't serve four years then let's do
it
50 50. i'm not doing this even money i'm
not doing 50 50. do you think is that 70
50 chance
no i think it's less than 50. i think i
think you have an entire outcome today
for me to be held accountable to
agree to do a bet with you on this thing
you you really think this guy's not
going to end this term
he will not finish his term tell me
about you tell me your health
i'll bet you on this one he's
cognitively interviewed see how he runs
up the stairs when he goes on the planes
like oh yeah he's running the stair
master
looks great to me i mean
let me tell you why there's a hundred
percent chance that he's gonna still be
president until 2024.
because he the democratic party is so
invested in him
that even if they have to weaken bernie
style him and he's just walking around
with sunglasses on
they're gonna probably probably they're
pressing them up big time but
they can't they will not be able to prop
them up for four more years no chance
i i disagree it's just too big
are you willing to do a 50-50 bet what's
the number what have 10 grand
no i'm not being 10 grand joe but 10
grand right now
that he's going to still be the
president i say he will not be the
president
through the end of his term that's
actually a good bet if you're thinking
about it
a thousand bucks right deal
oh my gosh we got the bet so yeah
and listen by the way if you're
listening uh uh for whatever reason i'm
i i
you can't collect my money because i
collected a lot of money when buying one
there's a guy named ricky aguilar that
still owes me a thousand dollars so
hopefully he shows up
and uh we can work that out i'm gonna
keep prodding that guy do it so but but
here's the thing here's the thing
let's qualify yeah if he gets impeached
does that count as not me
hear me out if he's not the president so
whether he's impeached he resigns he
steps down whatever happens if he
doesn't finish his term
that's correct he dies he steps down for
health reasons he's not going to get
impeachment
impeachment's impossible yeah i don't
think all right so we got so 1000 bucks
full time
yeah circle back in four years why are
you so confident about this
because i just don't think he's he you
can see it i mean he looks like a deer
you know what you're doing and i used to
be the same victim i learned i learned
from pat
you're a victim of your emotions right
now i'm i'm a zero man
i got zero emotional attachment to this
i'm just gonna make a thousand bucks and
call it a day
thank you sleepy joe good luck getting
up the stairs did you watch the press on
the stairs i don't care
but anybody can fall upstairs did you
watch the press conference this guy
this guy when he walks out of the press
conference he doesn't know what state
he's in
this guy can't find his car in a
7-eleven parking lot with four spot i
mean this guy is lost he's emotionally
invested you're emotionally invested not
i just watch him he doesn't know where
he is i mean he loses he's just he's
cognitively going down quickly and there
someone's going to step in or he's going
to step down
or they'll make it they'll make it
they'll do it in a dignified manner
they'll say look he's got some health
problems
and they're probably trying to make it
last past the second year
because midterms well they want to make
it past so that way they can run kamala
twice
or three times i mean she can serve two
years and i'll tell you right now
she could run kamala harris is not going
to be our future president i'm telling
you i'm just saying let me ask you a
question
let me ask you a question i've got a
crazy question for you kamala harris
is on the ticket 2024 and trump's on the
right who are you voting for
who's the third party who's the third
party forget about it third party is joe
jorgensen
let's go joe let's go joe
half our audience doesn't even know that
joe jorgensen is actually a female they
don't know that he has that question i'm
all in on joe jordan
the libertarian party of the green party
actually had a charismatic figure
we've been saying this foreign
ralph nader get out of here you can't
win in those parties
but wait a minute who is the most
charismatic libertarian
who's the most charismatic libertarian
independent canada we've had well
i mean you look at a guy like uh ron
paul
um he said charismatic well i mean you
know in his own way i mean he's not
donald trump he's not he's not a
bombastic type of person yeah you get
some
money behind you how about ross perrault
yeah he's the reason that bill was the
president yeah that was 30 years ago
it's just very difficult yeah that was
30 years ago by the way
i tell you i don't know why i actually
think there is a big opportunity if the
right charismatic guy goes
out there i think there's a big
opportunity for the rock
of mark cuban charismatic if someone
who's like liv
i got this i care about you you know who
you know matthew mcconaughey
actually i'm actually being serious
matthew mcconaughey matthew mcconaughey
if you get
somebody like you're saying no chance no
chance you know there was another actor
that ended up becoming the governor
ended up becoming a president i don't
know if you remember the guy his name
was ronald reagan yeah do you remember
that guy i do
pretty good guy yep did you vote for him
i did but you also voted for jimmy
carter
i voted for jimmy carter in 76 i voted
for
a third party candidate naively in 1980
john anderson
you didn't vote for reagan in 80. i
didn't no i thought i thought oh my god
i thought i
honestly thought about reagan the way
lots of people today think about trump i
mean this guy's crazy this guy's just
he's gonna bring us into world war three
he's talking about evil empires and the
soviets and
i thought oh my god i mean because we
had just got done with it yeah we got
our audience who is maybe a little bit
younger that doesn't remember what
reagan was talking about in 1979 1980
what was that
he was just talking about you know the
the the axis of evil and and
and the the the russians and the i mean
i thought my god
he's going to usher us into world war
three we're going into nuclear war
and you know i was still a young guy we
had just got done with vietnam i mean i
didn't want to go to vietnam i was too
young
and it was over just about the time i
would have
matured into the point where i could
have been drafted and you know we were
scared to death to have to go to vietnam
and i thought my god this guy's crazy
not only that he just seemed kind of
affable and stupid and just
but by 1984 he was the the
the the effable dunce that he was
turns out he was way smarter than i
thought he was way smarter than anybody
he ever gave him credit for being
and he was ideologically where i was by
the time the mid 80s came along so by 84
he had turned the economy around i mean
if you remember i mean just you just go
back to pop culture you can see it on
saturday night live i mean jimmy carter
i mean this guy
nice guy i mean you know meant well but
completely ineffective
and he got on television he's talking to
people look we have an energy crisis
the world's going to be running out of
oil by 1985
and we need to turn down our thermostats
and put on a sweater and everybody's
like
this is what he said i mean this is the
crazy stuff and reagan's like hell we're
america we can kick ass let's just come
in and
what is this guy crazy i mean i had
heard four years of carter i liked
carter
but i realized by 1980 that carter
wasn't getting it done i mean we were
being made fools of by the iranians they
had these hostages
it was and reagan came in and like the
na the day he gets inaugurated
pow's right they let the hostages go
because they were not going to mess with
reagan
and you know he just everything he did
in four years was just amazing
since reagan so you were it sounds like
you were kind of a little bit
lefty you're in your 20s and then you
you've heard this reagan came in show me
a
show me a a young conservative i'll show
you a man with no heart show me an old
liberal i'll show you a man with no
brain
there it is so you went from so in a
heart to heaven
who's a better president carter or biden
well are they very similar uh
no uh carter was probably better
carter better than biden carter was
intelligent
what do you put but biden is an
immigrant has always been an imbecile
now he's a senile imbecile
okay he's not running anything they put
papers in front of him
they say sign this and he's you know he
signs it what am i signing wait he signs
it
and then if he if he happens to get a
little feisty if they put a paper in
front of him
here's your 47th executive order you're
signing this he reads he says
what the hell is this oh we're uh we're
mandating that our
daughters are going to have to compete
with men in sports
uh i don't want to sign this and they
said joe sign it just sign it
he's like i'm not saying i'm wait a
minute i'm the president i'm the
freaking president i'm not doing
they say joe do we have to remind do we
have to remind you joe
that we have a lot of dirt on you china
and ukraine and all this stuff
we can throw you under the bus and you
will not be president nobody's saying
that today
absolutely are you kidding me who's
saying that joe listen sign the damn
thing or we're going to we're going to
expose you
in the democratic party nobody's saying
that absolutely he is literally doing
what they tell him and if
he doesn't do what they tell him they
will throw him under the bus and they
will gladly put commodities
legitimate question for you who's they i
have no idea all right
i mean it's the powers the powers you
know how is that whether whether it's
susan right i don't know who the hell it
is but q a
it's q a it's the person but i'm telling
you there are people that are running
joe
whoever's running joe biden because he
is truly a puppet someone's got the
strings
and if he doesn't do what they say they
will throw him out because they're gonna
put him on goat mountain like the
greatest of all time president what do
you put on
biden yeah yeah abraham lincoln george
washington are you are you of uh uh are
you in a place
completely it's it's a joke it's a
complete joke of a
i mean i can't believe that there's no
way 80 million people voted for this guy
there's just no way but because
if they did 85 million i cannot imagine
that
i mean i get on tell you watch this guy
on television i mean he is completely
lost byron do you think that donald
trump should be
on mount rushmore legitimate question
i'm not going there
what do you mean i put reagan up there
first okay
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye